Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
12 mars 2050.
Aujourd'hui,
l'humanité atteint la neutralité carbone.
Je vais profiter de cette date historique
pour vous raconter comment tous ensemble,
on y est arrivé.
Comment on a réussi
en une centaine d'années à unir nos forces
pour résoudre l'un des plus grands défis
auquel l'humanité était confrontée.
Je vais vous raconter cette histoire
qui a commencé dans les années 1960
lorsque les premiers scientifiques
sont allés forer en Antarctique
et se sont rendu compte
qu'on avait un problème avec le climat.
Je vais vous montrer
les trois grandes étapes
qui nous ont permis
de prendre des tournants décisifs.
Ces trois grandes étapes,
elles ont été essentielles pour lutter
contre ce dérèglement climatique.
Et même aujourd'hui, ici en 2050,
même si on a eu des catastrophes,
même si on a eu des échecs,
on peut vraiment dire
que ce dérèglement climatique
a été une formidable opportunité
pour nous rassembler
et nous permettre d'agir
pour un monde plus durable et plus juste.
La première de ces trois étapes,
c'est l'impulsion au niveau global.
Cette impulsion, elle a commencé avec ça.
Ça, c'est un verre de whisky.
En 1965, Claude Lorius,
quand il était en hivernage
en Terre Adélie,
s'est rendu compte
en mettant des glaçons dans son whisky
que les petites bulles
que ces glaçons libéraient
étaient des témoins fiables et uniques
de la composition de l'air
lorsque la glace s'était formée.
C'est ces petites bulles-là
qui nous ont permis
ensuite de reconstruire
l'ensemble,
sur des centaines de milliers d'années,
le climat passé.
Là on voit sur les 2 000 dernières années,
qu'on a eu
un petit réchauffement climatique médieval
un petit âge glaciaire,
et ensuite un réchauffement
climatique très important
depuis l'industrialisation.
Et avec ces petites bulles
piégées dans la glace,
on peut remonter
dans les 800 000 dernières années
de notre Terre.
On voit qu'on a eu des températures plus
importantes que celles d'aujourd'hui.
Mais ce qui marque vraiment
le réchauffement d'aujourd'hui,
c'est qu'il est 100 fois plus rapide
que tous les réchauffements dans le passé,
et qu'il est dû aux activités de l'homme.
Pour faire face à ce problème,
la communauté internationale a fait
ce qu'elle sait faire de mieux :
elle a créé des acronymes.
Elle a créé d'abord le GIEC en 1988.
C'est un groupe de scientifiques
faisant l'état de l'art de la connaissance
scientifique sur les sujets du climat.
Ils ont ensuite créé des rapports,
d'année en année toujours plus alarmants,
qui disaient : « Si on ne fait rien,
on va droit dans le mur. »
La communauté internationale s'est dit :
« Il faut d'autres solutions. »
Ils ont alors créé les COP pour essayer
de trouver des solutions entre les États.
Et moi, à l'époque,
je voulais m'investir sur ces thématiques,
et je me suis dit
que c'est vraiment au niveau global
qu'on allait y arriver.
Et c'est pour ça que je me suis investi
dans l'équipe COP21.
On a eu un succès
incroyable avec la COP21,
parce que contrairement
aux précédentes COP,
on a mis autour de la table tous les
acteurs, pas que les gouvernements.
On a mis la société civile,
on a mis les entreprises,
tous les citoyens
qui voulaient participer,
ce qui nous a permis
d'aboutir à cet Accord de Paris.
Là on s'est dit à ce moment-là :
« On est sauvé !
On a résolu le problème du
dérèglement climatique au niveau global,
on a un accord entre tous les États,
c'est génial, maintenant, c'est
derrière nous et on peut avancer. »
Et ça, c'était sans compter
les échecs des COP suivantes,
ni l'arrivée à la tête de l'une
des grandes nations du monde
de l'un des présidents
les plus climato-sceptiques.
Là, il y avait un problème.
A l'élection de Donald Trump,
c'était lors de la deuxième semaine
des négociations à la COP22,
l'ambiance était particulière :
les négociateurs étaient désemparés.
Ils pensaient :
« Ce qu'on fait depuis 21 ans,
ça a servi à ça,
ça n'a servi presque à rien,
et finalement il faut
recommencer de zéro. »
Et là on s'est dit qu'il y avait un
vrai problème avec ce niveau global
pour agir contre
le dérèglement climatique.
En parallèle de ça, on a vu
la deuxième grande étape,
qui s'est passée :
ce sont les catastrophes
naturelles qui se sont multipliées.
Rien qu'en 2019,
on avait plus de 1 100
catastrophes naturelles.
Ça comporte des incendies, des canicules,
des inondations, des cyclones.
Et ces catastrophes naturelles
arrivaient encore plus vite
que ce que le GIEC nous avait prédit.
Et elles touchaient toutes
les parties du monde.
On se rappelle en 2020 des incendies
énormes qui ont touché l'Australie,
poussant même les plus climato-sceptiques
à dire qu'on avait un vrai problème
avec le dérèglement climatique.
En parallèle de ça,
on avait des milliers de scientifiques qui
publiaient des tribunes pour nous dire :
« Si on continue comme ça,
on va à la catastrophe,
il faut absolument
qu'on fasse quelque chose. »
Et ça, dans les années 2020,
ça a conduit à deux types de discours.
Le premier, celui des
climato-sceptiques :
« Finalement, on n'a pas de
problème de dérèglement climatique.
Puis : « Ce n'est pas dû
aux activités de l'homme. »
On a eu un autre discours assez
négatif : celui des collapsologues.
« C'est la fin du monde. On va construire
un bunker, on va tous s'y réfugier.
Et on va attendre que
vraiment ce monde se finisse. »
Et ça, c'était vraiment très
intense dans les années 2020.
Et on a vu ensuite
arriver la troisième étape,
celle qui a marqué un tournant dans
la lutte contre le dérèglement climatique.
Cette troisième étape,
elle propose une alternative
aux discours des climato-sceptiques
et des collapsologues.
C'est l'action au niveau local.
On a vu alors, dans les années 2020,
émerger des récits positifs qui parlaient
plutôt des solutions que des problèmes,
en poussant femmes et hommes
à agir au niveau local
et à voir les effets de leurs actions.
On a arrêté d'attendre un messie,
un super-héros qui allait
nous sauver au niveau global
et nous dire quoi faire.
On a aussi arrêté les discours du type
« Pourquoi je bougerais si
les Chinois ne font rien ? »
ou alors « Pourquoi dans ma maison,
je vais éteindre mes lumières,
pourquoi j'irais au travail en vélo,
alors que tous mes collègues
ne le font pas ? »
C'est vraiment intéressant,
parce que ces solutions
se développaient autant dans
les pays du nord que du sud,
et principalement
dans les zones les plus touchées
par les effets du dérèglement climatique.
C'est par exemple le cas des Alpes,
avec un emblême des Alpes :
la Mer de glace.
Voilà la Mer de glace
dans les années 1900 ;
ça, c'est la Mer de glace
dans les années 2020.
On avait une disparition presque
complète de cette Mer de glace.
Et pour aller à la rencontre de ceux qui
trouvaient des solutions dans les Alpes,
j'avais décidé d'y aller
en faisant une traversée des Alpes
en marchant et en volant en parapente.
Si vous ne connaissez pas,
c'est un formidable moyen de se
déplacer et de faire des rencontres :
on sait où on décolle le matin, on
ne sait jamais où on va atterrir le soir.
On rencontre des personnes qui, au niveau
local, trouvent des solutions incroyables.
Et pour raconter tout ce bouillonnement
qui existait au niveau local,
j'ai décidé à l'époque de créer
une collection de documentaires.
Cette collection de
documentaires « Il faut sauver »,
on l'a créée avec une équipe de
professionnels de la télé et des récits
pour vraiment montrer
des récits optimistes positifs,
qui contrastaient avec les documentaires
catastrophistes qu'on avait à l'époque.
Ça a vraiment pour but
que des millions de téléspectateurs,
après avoir vu les épisodes,
se lèvent et aient envie de
passer à l'action au niveau local.
Dans le 1er épisode,
« Il faut sauver les Alpes »,
on a vu beaucoup
de solutions au niveau local -
ces cinq-là -
qui étaient prises par des personnes,
pas forcément pour réduire
leurs émissions de CO₂,
mais pour avoir des effets bénéfiques
dans d'autres domaines.
Ça peut être la santé humaine,
l'amélioration de leur pouvoir d'achat,
ou bien recréer du lien social
dans des sociétés
où on était de plus en plus isolé.
On a par exemple
la « Remorque des producteurs »,
où on a quatre producteurs locaux
qui sont associés,
pour qu'il n'y ait qu'une
personne à faire les marchés.
Ça permet d'économiser mille heures
de travail par an pour chaque producteur,
d'éviter d'émettre
trois tonnes de CO₂ par an,
et en plus, ça leur fait un gain de vente.
On avait une autre solution :
le « Repair café »,
un collectif de citoyens
qui, dans la vallée de l'Arve,
s'est formé pour réparer
des objets plutôt que de les jeter.
En réparant l'électroménager,
on gagne du pouvoir d'achat,
puisqu'on n'en achète pas du neuf,
et on évite aussi de rejeter des polluants
atmosphériques dus à l'incinération.
Et pour aller plus loin
que ces documentaires,
on a décidé avec notre équipe
de créer une interface.
Cette interface,
c'est le carrefour des solutions
pour accélérer la transition
écologique au niveau local.
Dans cette interface, il y a deux piliers.
Le premier pilier, c'est les recettes.
C'est comme Marmiton :
si vous voulez faire un brownie,
vous allez y prendre la recette.
Là, si vous voulez faire une station
d'épuration personnelle, un repair café,
ou une remorque des producteurs,
si vous êtes producteur,
vous allez aller sur cette interface
et vous allez de façon très simple
pouvoir répliquer ces solutions.
Le deuxième pilier de cette interface
est une fabrique à solutions.
Sur le terrain, on a constaté qu'il y
avait beaucoup de points de blocage.
Par exemple, un restaurateur a vu
sa consommation de viande rouge
augmenter de 200% en un an.
Ces points de blocage,
on les a fait remonter,
et on a créé tout un réseau d'experts,
un réseau de compétences,
pour trouver des solutions
à ces points de blocage.
Par exemple pour le restaurateur,
il y a une école d'ingénieurs
qui a créé une application
pour donner un code couleur
au poids carbone de ses menus.
Et donc on a vu à l'époque
des millions de personnes
rejoindre ce mouvement,
ces récits positifs,
pour s'impliquer sur ces thématiques,
et on avait enfin compris
qu'en agissant au niveau local,
on avait un pouvoir fort et direct
au niveau global.
Cette transition au niveau local est une
roue crantée de la transition écologique.
Dès qu'on fait un progrès,
aucun retour en arrière n'est possible.
Et ça, c'est assez intéressant
parce qu'avec ces comportements,
ce qui guidait nos comportements,
c'est quelque chose
qui est ancré dans notre cerveau,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le striatum.
Ce striatum,
il va sécréter de la dopamine,
nous récompenser dans les actions
pour assurer la survie de notre espèce.
Il assure la survie de notre espèce
en maintenant cinq objectifs.
Ces cinq objectifs, c'est :
le besoin en nourriture,
le sexe, le besoin d'information,
la reconnaissance sociale
et la paresse.
Et ça,
le marketing au XXème siècle avait bien
compris comment fonctionnait le cerveau.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on a vu plein
de pubs comme ça apparaître
des milliards d'euros investis
dans ces publicités-là,
en nous faisant croire que
c'est en ayant un gros 4x4
qu'on allait avoir
plus de reconnaissance sociale
et qu'on allait avoir plus de conquêtes.
Donc à l'époque, on disait qu'il fallait
on ait plus, mieux que son voisin,
qu'on avait des portables très chers
ou les dernières paires de chaussures.
Et en 2020, on s'est dit
qu'on ne pouvait plus continuer comme ça.
Il y a donc eu plein de mouvements
destinés à changer le fonctionnement
de notre striatum.
On a par exemple le flygskam, la honte de
prendre l'avion qui est apparue en Suède,
en disant que,
les personnes qui prennent l'avion pour
passer leurs vacances au bout du monde,
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on va sécréter
de la dopamine.
Pour sécréter cette dopamine, on a vu
des changements opérés très importants :
on participait aux marches
pour le climat,
on s'associait avec
des collectifs de citoyens
pour réfléchir aux problèmes auxquels
nos sociétés faisaient face,
pour participer à des jardins partagés,
ou créer de l'électricité renouvelable
avec des collectifs citoyens.
Et c'est vraiment un changement
qui a été majeur.
On a vu plus de gens
s'investir dans leur vie personnelle.
Et une fois investies,
elles ont voulu aller encore plus loin.
Elles ont voulu transformer leurs écoles,
leurs entreprises, leurs institutions,
leurs régions, leurs municipalités,
de l'intérieur,
en proposant des solutions
et en étant vraiment force de proposition.
Et même les dirigeants,
même les décideurs politiques
pas encore convaincus
du problème
avec le dérèglement climatique,
ils ont été forcés
de rejoindre le mouvement.
Et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
en ce jour du 12 mars 2050,
on peut être très fier
de ce qu'on a mené,
toute l'énergie et toute la motivation
dépensées au niveau local
pour accélérer cette transition
tous ensemble.
Je pense vraiment qu'on peut se dire un
grand merci et un grand bravo aujourd'hui.
(Applaudissements)